[Music]  Jessica Biel stuns during date night out  with Justin Timberlake oh it was so fun  a couple hit up W Magazine three Golden  Globes bash at the Chateau Marmont in  Los Angeles on Thursday night  check out 34 year old Jess looking after  Lizzy gorgeous and a chic black velvet  wrap dress paired with strappy heels  that warms my little cold heart justin  looked sharp in an all-black look  including a beanie and tan boots the  couples night out comes just days after  JT showed off his impressive v-ball  skillz I'm gonna check that off the list  yeah last year Jessica told it to you  and an ideal date night is like for the  duo well I kind of like old-fashioned  date dinner movie really make out dinner  movie  [Music]  you